I don't think anyone predicted Justin
getji had kick KO it was brilliant
though why no one thought about that it
makes sense because Dustin Porter was
doing a good job neutralizing light
kicks if you're just in gaichi or his
coach like he knows he's gonna be
focused on the light kicks let's go up
top the writing was on the wall just no
one saw it before the fight having some
success with it I gave Dustin party the
first round but I thought it doesn't get
you look good he's definitely proved me
wrong you know Trevor Whitman just gets
you go I don't fight like I used to you
know I've changed my game I'm fighting
smarter but I still have that berserk
Enemy by him fighting smarter 100 he
showed it on Saturday night he's
fighting a lot smarter a lot more
calculated and he doesn't spurt so do
that kind of crazed you know Wolverine
Tasmanian Devil burst every now and then
but he it's under control now and it
showed in this Dustin Poirier fight